+15 nostalgia +20 cloud and - hundred
cereal what's up everybody today we're
looking at our item shun where we take
real life items into the video game
world wait why
remember this spoon if you don't
remember the spoon your childhood poof
not there I don't remember where I got
this spoon from but I remember it was
the greatest spoon of all time I had one
of those I wish I still had mine where
do they come from the existence eraser
wow that's got to be a rare item at
least a stick a Batman armor plus 100%
stealth in urban jungle condition
mastery in urban jungle movement that's
pretty hella freaking dope nunchucks are
legal in some states but guns are not so
if you tie two guns and create gun
Chuck's got Chuck's it's neither legal
or it's Schrodinger's cat of weapons
everyone weapon of brass destruction
threat eliminated that's freaking badass
where can i buy one this whole sub red
is like oh I want that yeah yeah can i
buy that of ebay a tuba Sharyl freakin a
via - but white knuckle sandwich when
you stone any racist enemy the enemy
will instantly die
hey racism I brought you simple lunch
what with air pod in his ear you know
he's ready to deliver some epic brofist
towards races no wait
dammit I thought he was the CEO of
racism that's why I had the earpods
when you're low level character finds a
rare item I don't know why that took me
so long like I look at the image first
okay that's funny comment how my Glock
extremely powerful ranged weapon uses
both mana and Oh wolf mana and ammo damn
so that seems like a terrible idea I'm
just gonna go ahead and say it terrible
bad bad bad idea not epic idea although
it'd be a freaking cool way to kill
someone
you'd probably take out your wrists and
I don't even know how you would fire
that thing but ma'am that is some epic
hood I assume he's in the hood because
of the background and now no other
reason fish socks for this item you can
walk on water
what how much are they I want that
that's so cool
damn this reminds me of when I was a kid
this is like one of my worst
realizations all right you guys remember
Action Man Action Man the greatest hero
of them all
I saw the figurine but I thought you
wouldn't get the figurine I thought you
got like the scuba equipment all right
it didn't look like this it looked like
a realistic photo on the package so
naturally I'm like that's freaking epic
mom can we please buy an Action Man
figurine I didn't know it wasn't the
scoop i won it was the one where you
climb he had like these suction cups
things to climb with and I'm like wait
I've seen those in films they always use
imagine my disappointment when I found
out their suction cups weren't a real
thing I would get a lousy figurine this
is false it was false advertising and it
crushed my hopes and dreams and you know
what I might just buy their real things
right now
eBay freaking now I'm a millionaire and
I'm an adult and I'll get those suction
cups suction cup wall climber I don't
even care I'll get the suction cup
things
god damn it can someone make me suction
cups climbing things because I was
planning to climb my best friend's house
and be like low precise ohms veil plus
40 dampness plus Terrell charisma
you may now Shawn oh you can charm
fishes with that that looks pretty cool
that is actually a pretty epic outfit
hey look it's mysterion everyone not so
good how do you even put that on that's
amazing that seems kind of dangerous but
if in danger break glass but then the
fishes will die agate if in danger do
nothing
fishes will live don't worry
lefty-loosey righty-tighty Depok you
guys know that the quick Nichkhun is a
Swedish invention you are welcome gamers
why did I tell you that I just thought
I'd tell you yeah yeah
there it is you're welcome we also
invented digital health what oat milk
really we didn't do anything better pace
Mac ok pacemakers but damn sweeteners in
lame dude zipper we did the zipper holy
freaking moly you have a zipper right
now thank me mega monster monster 3l
mega monster drink we'll give you 2000
health and 100 strength listen I could
do that with you fuel that would give
you literally night vision it would give
you levitation and it would give you mad
push you don't want to drink that
garbage that's gonna make you die
ammo turtle randomly giving ammo for the
current weapon sometimes players of a 50
Cal shot plus 50% reserve ammo that's
pretty good I'll take one of those will
be your best friend and companion in
life Oh awesome I'll take five thank you
an extra storage pink picture of the MVP
carrying his teammates what is this what
am I looking at it's a trash bin but I
think it's just a trash bin ok infant
armor of God where can i buy this in
flicks minus 50 motivation ok fine
permanent - 100 moral for Weaver's you
can't shoot me you can't tase me
you can't gas me you can't even knock me
down
not without something very fragile and
very precious going squish you know what
they should do they should take all
their annoying kits and airplanes and
just make armor out of them literally
any come oh god this is dangerous I'm
sharing information that could have
severe consequences for our lives
because any government that utilizes
this technology it's going to inevitably
win all the worse
a tank peepee no it's a tank silencer
fire here tank with those boys is that
what it is I kind of think it it is it
I'm so confused
I don't know man seems kind of gay to me
I'll take two one for my tank and one
for my peepee brofist cuz I was epic
come on I'm confused what is that
someone tell me I'm sure someone knows I
pray I hear some I want that that's cool
choo-choo on this flip flop the one
weapon to take down Thomas himself the
Lord of the underworld I don't think
that scope works I'm gonna be honest
with you guys and technically you're
staring down Thomas [ __ ] and I don't
know what I feel about that
it's that real I can't tell it wouldn't
surprise me if it was real god I hate
Thomas the Tank Engine it was always on
TV and I never liked it and now as an
adult it scares me hey stop can you just
not exist bladed weapons confiscated
from rioters by the Paris police of
course get it gets their fridge Swedish
people use grenadiers meatballs
yeah not that my lunch ah
Drita imagine the humiliation of getting
stabbed by one of these Nugget increases
saturation by 75% enables nugget boss
battle when used in caves nugget what am
I gonna do with a nugget I can't throw
that await second it's like a mini
meatball isn't it I just realized
nuggets are literally meatballs because
it's all grinded chicken well I guess we
all learned something new here today
free soup extreme I've seen it it's
extremely rare and difficult to find
gives you thousand XP thousand XP points
raises your damage abilities plus 50 but
lowers entity to one free soup free soup
you're going to be so so cursed free
soup I'll never say no to free soup
I don't care where it comes from or what
it is I'm going for the free soup this
is like when you have the suspicious
soup in Minecraft you never know what
you're gonna get
it's like a box of chocolates soup is
like a box of chocolates
Gabanna stuff of cryptid summon 24 TV
golems okay I'll take 24 when you spend
all your XP leveling up just your
starter whip so they added a bigger
emanation a silencer and longer BP and
stock epic beer cloak yeah that's a rare
item right there that's got to be at
least purple beer cloak +3 charisma
minus 5 stealth I want one I'd be sick
changed my life this is I'm experiencing
the exact same thing I experienced as a
child where I see these things and in my
head I wanted but now I know they're not
real and it still make us sad Jesus
Christ plus thousand damage +5
intimidation - time ability yeah it does
come with a cost and I don't even know
how you reload I think to be honest
deals hundred and twenty damage instant
male enemies or deals 200 damage to all
people type enemies they'll go to that
one gun to put an end to bailed out now
that's too dark I'm sorry don't hurt any
girl take my advice gamers don't hurt
any girl what am I looking at here Aspen
Pole 25 damage to vampires ignores any
armored bow ok the power of an ef5
tornado can do a piece of wood through
cement
how how damn - 50 oh my god
that's some Dark Souls I want it I want
it is it on eBay see here we are again
this is what I get what what even is
that what is she holding why is she
holding a pickle it all comes back to
the same helm of sight +3 perception +1
defense -3 charisma why that making no
sense has affinity for spiders and flies
okay what am I looking at here why does
your sword have those things in the
middle of the blade
it's called stab occurs it helps me with
my mad
what kind of math do you do with the
sword long division nah I'm just kidding
ah that's got to give a lot of extra
intelligence Catherine see oh I get it
worth 200 gold but may only be exchanged
with the Cultus faction fair enough I'll
hang on today you never know the books
of knowledge what they teach you at
Harvard Business School and what they
don't teach you at Harvard Business
School they're both very rare and hard
to come by but combined and you have
obtained the sum total of all human
knowledge you'll finally know what
Obama's last name is damn tampon myself
Wow
oh damn that's a lot of damage cool too
took out a cheetah huh that's awesome
mega Karen just look at the hair you
know her name is mega Karen 3a I kid
minions who crowd controlled by taking
enemy weapons damn it
elongated truck plus 50 storage - 75
speed could be a trade worth taking
depends what kind of quest you're on uh
yeah welcome traveler what can I do you
for
we serve swords and swords and more
swords would you like one Tobler on and
on and on and on
extremely rare legendary food damn full
HP and mana damn 40 years damn that's
awesome kind of seeing can zoom - Adam
waits eighty no attachment can be added
but from level four rare wandering
traveler Wow
in case you need to take out some peas
yes yes the door of Garda absorbs 50%
damage reflects 20% damage 25 even Wow
what I feel like they're hitting the
door at the hinges and that's what's
happening but that's just maybe that's
where you are supposed to do flame gator
companion Oh awesome
it's a rare pet since fire to everything
around it
Onix that's a tough train - five-step +
hundred fear I want it I want it can i
buy it on ebay leaves glass cannon 150
attack zero defense brakes on usage damn
spiked chronics attack fifteen defense
fifty mobility - 63 these are legit good
like life hacks incapable zombie
animation just spiked crocs epic flip
flop dead girls in sandals +10 charisma
makes every argument invalid I'm not I'm
not feeling that I don't like its face
stinky face stupid face is it actually
running sandals I thought it was
Photoshop oh my god it's aku's wearing
sandals epic energy mask +5 stamina will
boost your energy but will make you look
very sleepy
just drink evil gamers 30% off 30% off
gamers and through the code Beauty pipe
oh I have a rare item check out the link
in the description you can now sign up
to make sure you get the new PewDiePie
flavor I've been drinking it right now
it's so good enter the code pee deep I
get 30% off gamers that's a rare item
backpack of luck luck 90 explosive
resistant hundred this hero has luck
British Marine who flung himself back
first onto a grenade to save his comrade
that is insane that gives me shivers
dude is that real that's so badass
the explosion room in the air his back
is his rug sack observed the blast and
he walked away with a nosebleed
and a headache I can't I don't believe
this
makes sense actually a pack rucksack can
be a formidable barrier especially it's
filled with a mixed material that
includes metal pieces these stop
Shrapnel's the material that makes up
the rock second holding it together has
to be strong material supposedly he had
a radio in there that's a lot of metal
that blows my mind heavy boots allow
wearer to walk with the slow NPC in that
way but this curtain I don't know if I
want that heavy boots can I use them to
kick the MPC to go faster lemon of Aging
plus 33 years how did I taste of this
lemon termites
[Music]
that's Photoshop I realize it's
Photoshop but it makes me laugh anyway
Harry Potter and the Prisoner of Azkaban
gives 50 health status effects sick for
ten seven seconds life region for ten
seconds as kebab everyone delicious orb
of horrible sorrow
curse of binding don't want it don't
want it take it away built this while
tripping hard no idea what it does not
trying it either Christ what is it it
looks legit
I want enough light they taste absolute
but it looks good random D buffs I said
what I say any soup I'll soup it up I'll
drink it I don't even give a Frick
chameleons are fun cuz they'll grab
anything you give them oh my god that's
so cute
combat chameleon feels half of the
damage of the weapon you I want what I
want the flaming crocodile I want the
ammo turtle and I want the chameleon
imagine the amount of destruction I
could release upon the world at last
suction cups wouldn't even be necessary
therapist snake 47 is it real
it can't hurt you snake 47 I'm so
confused
I have so many questions but
looks like a lethal weapon to me tea
cleaner Wow 50% chance of killing user
instantly okay fine
50% chance of cleaning your weapon and
giving it 25 electric damage charge Wow
55 percent chance of giving it
channeling buff that's awesome
I'll stick my G fuel in there what
synthetic bro no freaking way that guy's
got to be a billionaire synthetic brah
they did it finally at last dog pockets
summon chunk dog or to fight for you
plus hundred dog I'll get a paddle get a
pack I guess I can buy a pack of them
Hedgehog dog Mountain
I'll take them out that's awesome what
level do you need to be able to use it
vegan Paige and Parker consume to heal
200 amma joke eh that's pretty good
throw an enemy to deal 150 poison damage
oh my god vegan poison taco pizza your
pigeon poison tax help the gigabyte
played legendary melee weapon lower in
description in the comments basically
people make it up that's great oh my god
Wow okay
crafting hero bird saves guy from $300
fine bird drone unlocked by completing
level 50 of the bird ruins plus 50
evasion plus 20 speed special 5% chance
to dodge any attack wow there's so many
epic Birds
items what in tactical tuna has a zero
10% chance to shoot out any species of
tuna what so you can get your lunch as
well
awesome oh my god your unbreakable
weapon with the near infinite
destruction power you're near my god I
want it can you play snake on it you
know I never had this model everyone
else had this model and everyone else
played snake and I could never play
snake it's fine really
avocado fertility couldn't seem for 50%
higher chance of birthing on air Wow
such a rare item I
consume it Madras chancla level-one
Madras chuckler level 67 damn so it is
worth the upgrade hun I was done oh my
god IKEA's priest can be found on the
map with the sidequest dismantling
furniture thousand elf
well drops ikea talisman that gives you
a 5% defense boost can trade a random
IKEA instructions with it will help you
screw the bed oh there it is told them
of ultimate speed allows you to run at
ten times the speed so long as you're
running Wow incredible cat-themed jar
all right I'll take one sixty nine
twelve stance wow that's nice ultimate
knowledge upon being read gives to
either 999 points boost in all stats can
be used once per reader wow that is too
much power for one person to know
absolutely incredible what do you guys
think I've carries more knowledge the
both of the hardwood books or all of the
Minecraft books I'll let you be the
judge
all I know is those are all combined
freaking orange stats Bible too of
course
why has no one done this before and why
have I never seen this before there it
is well now we all know combat glove
crocs plus 90 99 confusion they look
comfy they look hard to take off
actually I don't know about them it
looks like they have cursive binding bag
of snakes for when you need all the
snakes all right yeah I'll get a
freaking bag of snakes why can i buy it
I'll get a bag of snakes you can't stop
me emotional support shoot sorry what
the emotional support shoe is an item
that heals any emotional wound instantly
and for Teavana why does she have a
unibrow does it come with a unibrow I
don't know about it I don't know about
it aluminum water will make you strong
like metal I drink for all ages
including baby minus 60 speed that's
that makes sense aluminum water
interesting milk with a powdered milk in
it my god you've officially taken it
too far that's too powerful I mean
that's almost as powerful as my own
special flavor of gpo I feel the power
surging through my body my people grow
extra-large epic Wow
vessel of the gods plus 100 mobility I
didn't even know that was freaking
possible it takes 25 health due to ankle
injuries that's fair everything comes
with a price
minecraft grass cubes play simple item
ken block enemies has 50 health from
blocking and ammo deals what that's a
lot of damage
demonic Sunday plus 90 evil Plus 10
curse string epic I want one
alright gamers that's all from the item
shop that was really fun thanks Dave
actually for recommending this sub ready
that's it if you want check out the
March you know the drill I appreciate it
and see you gamers next time Mike and
subscribe read it week it's a thing now
well you haven't tried to personal a
turd saves me after 50 million out
troops by etch down just now it's still
relevant
just down